it seems to me that we are now letting
anyone and everyone gladly walk into
this country and if you say anything
about it they will call you of course a
racist or a Nazi take a look at a little
bit of a compilation of videos that are
just from the last week what's going on
at our
border
right
I love you Joe Biden thank you for
everything Joe Biden I'm good person I
want to be good person here in the
United States I came here because I want
quality life you know America is a is a
land of
opportunity ASA what happened to what it
says on the Statue of Liberty something
about you're poor you're tired your
huddled masses these people all look
relatively young they look relatively
healthy and wellfed most of them the
large percentage of them are male uh we
don't do any vetting on any of these
people it's very nice that he thinks
America is pretty great he actually
thinks America is better than most
progressives seem to think it is uh but
you you can't not have a border no you
have to have a border and having
traveled many borders I know how hard it
is to cross them you know I have tried
to cross between India and Pakistan not
easy into Afghan bet you that one's not
easy yeah it was not easy do you know
what I mean I was at the corner of India
at at the China border I wasn't going to
be able to take a step into China you
know it just doesn't happen anywhere
else in the world like we have allowed
such a porous system and as an immigrant
I can testify to everything that we just
heard about the beauty of America the
world over wants to come here except for
the progressives that want to exactly
taint our beautiful Nation but we must
be a nation of laws and ultimately what
what is the connective tissue in all of
this there is an ideology happening
sweeping through this nation in which it
is transforming the identities of
children allowing the identity of what
it means to be an American to be
hijacked and ultimately Waging War with
those that should be our friends such as
the Jews and Israel and so it is a
hijacking of America from every front
from our inner selves to our external
relations with our allies and then our
borders
and the truth of the matter is that
there is a political motivation right
there's a motivation to try to change
demographics and congressional districts
and we have to be really clear about
that you know this isn't some Al
altruistic effort that's happening
there's multi-million dollar uh
organizations that are leading these
Caravans allowing the registration then
to voting taking away identity rules
when it comes to voting there's a a a a
trajectory that is meant to ultimately
inform seats in Congress and uh who the
identity of our politician will be in
the White House and so let's not be um
you know naive I think and and we
certainly aren't here at the round table
but let us not allow this nation to be
hijacked as it is today so John I I
think you're probably on board the
sentiment there about a nation being
hijacked but again I want to just bring
it to the law enforcement part for you
cuz that's your specialty uh so it's
sort of a same question that I asked you
about the NYPD but when you see the
Border guards there and they're just
letting them through and sometimes
they're literally opening up the door
there's like there's a door on some of
these fences they open up a door they
let 12 people through then they say wait
a second they tell them go that way to
Chicago go that way to San Diego I mean
I'm literally not making this stuff up
what is going on with that chain of
command and and do you have sympathy for
the guys that are there I kind of
sympathize with them I don't know how
they can do their job when they're being
basically told not to yeah look a very
good friend of mine was uh a border
patrol Intel uh he's now with Homeland
Security he's an agent there but um he
was back there about 15 20 years ago and
the situation was bad then you know and
uh but not like it is today the ranking
file not like the FBI the FBI Rank and
file now is very woke and and they are
in lock step with guys like Chris Ray so
when guys like Sean Hannity go the rank
and file it's nonsense I it's getting
worse in the bureau but the border
control these guys want to do their job
let me just say one thing about that
video so we watch that video As
Americans as conservatives we get
enraged right at 30,000 foot level we
see all these people pouring across
offence something not much scares me
that I watch something in that video
scared me I looked at about I watched
just now about 20 Chinese fighting aged
males and more than a few of them but a
dozen of them were very comfortable
standing at military parade rest while
waiting to be processed or turned around
that should be concerning if that's
their default stance mhm that should be
concerning that that many Chinese
fighting age males came through a fence
came through a hole in a
fence